ich bin sauschlecht in monga hat finde
allerdings das ist das geilste spiel des
jahres ist von daher schauen wir uns
heute im monat teams an
er läuft dahin
das blöd
kommen eigentlich diese ganzen im
mollers animationen her das ist
geisteskrank was leute da teilweise
animieren ich wie ich versuche zu
erklären dass ich nicht der post war
denn auch wenn ich gerade aus einem band
raus gehüpft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
in einer meiner ersten us roden war es
auch so dass ich einfach herum gelaufen
bin und überhaupt ich wusste was sie
machen sollte und dann hat ein emergency
meeting gemacht weil einfach meinte ja
hier lukas warum ihr müsst euch das
einfach mal vorstellen da sind zehn
leute irgendwo im universum alle
zusammen im gleichen raumschiff und nach
und nach sterben einfach random
irgendwelche leute und das einzige was
sie da die man sich fragen ist wo keiner
traut ihr richtig ich bin dafür
begründende petition dass bei jedem tod
erst mal so eine schweigeminute kommt
er oder sie lassen ich sage das ist oder
prozent nicht die wahrheit immer wenn
man so eine tat macht ist dann projekt
sich alles an roth am blinken jetzt
kommt ne fette gehört auch sinn denn die
täterin man selbst ist oder bei dieser
kreditkarte gerade so dadurch zu scannen
zum vierzigsten mal wenn 3d denn ich war
das nicht ich hab zum gleichen zeitpunkt
woanders wegen getötet ist genauso blöd
ich habe ja irgendwie vor ein paar tagen
im livestream auch noch runde gemacht wo
teile von euch ja auch mit dabei waren
teile von euch warten auf jeden fall
habe ich mit meinen leistungen hat mit
zuschauern am morgen als gespielt und
dann kamen halt teilweise auch ein
bisschen rennteams irgendwie in die
lobby plötzlich mit reid und irgendwann
die ganze tat komme und start und ich
denke das ist meine runde
du kommst auch nicht immer ein haus
einfach rein und sagt wir dann koch
jetzt wenn ich nicht kochen will
der vergleich macht katie holmes oder
kenne das wenn ihr einfach in irgendeine
random lobby reinschauen und auf einmal
ist das speed auf 70 milliarden prozent
unterdrückt gefühlt einmal auflaufen und
ihr seid gefühlt auf dem anderen
raumschiff menschenrechte sind sämtlich
abstoßen nicht der einzige der am
meisten fühlt wenn man ganz langsam
läuft es gibt im ganzen so viel dramatik
irgendwie orange source wer sagt denn
dass man selber als ein blauer roter
ich habe gern rot runter fliegen sehen
spam green wieder daniel adams 110 es
ist immer immer genauso du kannst die
geisteskrank ist den fakten und theorien
und belege und beweise und evidenz ihn
raus
h
nicht evident
[Musik]
absolut freiwillig mit teilweise videos
von anderen usern im monat angucke denke
ich mir immer nur so gut spielen und
danach unterhalten die sich wie gewesen
sein könnte
dann sind die wieder ruhig und dann
werde ich immer spiele mit irgendwelchen
leuten alle schreien dazwischen keiner
mietet sich so richtig sondern scheinbar
zwischen drüber
[Musik]
ja sondern
und ich auch schon mal ich vertrau
stephan j ist falsch
[Musik]
jeder geraden menschen
wenn man auf deutschland genommen als
public works schon gesagt egal
wie spielen wie spielen farben blinde
menschen eigentlich im monat schreibt
irgendwann in chat ja dass alle rot
worden
antwortet er dann dann grün
es ist ein rot grün schwäche nicht
hardcore gamer 6 100 und 6 0
[Musik]
war richtig
was ist das das ist eine mischung aus
einem offen
was ist das pinkeln
wo du lebst doch noch
das zeigt einfach ganz genau wie public
lobby cinemas ablaufen du kannst einfach
irgendwas schreiben
[Musik]
an der stelle ich das heute wieder
einige beende meine lieben freunde
spielt ihr selber schreibt sie mal gern
unten in die kommentare und dabei den
ganz kurze info ich bin nämlich gleich
um 20 uhr 13,11 krone